Salut ! Aujourd'hui pour le Mental Vlog, exceptionnellement je suis filmé par Monsieur Charles Hudon.
C'est lui qui est derrière la caméra mais tu ne le vois pas.
Je suis avec Kamille.
-Bonjour !
Avec un K.
Je suis ravi qu'on puisse faire cette vidéo ensemble, ça fait longtemps qu'on se connaît, c'est cool Kamille.
Et donc tu habites à Bordeaux ?
-Oui, et je t'avais découvert dans les Volte Vanne en plus. Dans ton premier passage du Volte Vanne.
Il a d'ailleurs était filmé par Charles Hudon. La boucle est bouclée. T'as vu il n'y a pas de coincidence ici.
Je voulais te laisser un cadeau aujourd'hui. Tu vois, comme la boucle est bouclée tu vas repartir avec un cadeau, c'est un carré magique.
Un carré magique, c'est un carré de 4 cases sur 4 cases, à l'intérieur duquel il y a des nombres ou des chiffres, par forcément consécutifs mais tous différents.
Et le but du jeu, c'est que la somme de chaque ligne et de chaque colonne soit identique à un seul et même résultat.
Et là, vous vous dites "on va bien se marrer dans le Mental Vlog".
J'ai juste besoin que tu me donne un nombre au-dessus de 34. Parce qu'en dessous ce n'est pas possible.
-Allez, je vais dire 75.
D'accord, 75. Tu aurais pu dire 444 pour déconner.
C'est parti !
Top !
-Il fait n'importe quoi ! Il fait le malin là...
Là on ne voit pas mais c'est un 4.
Alors il n'y a que des nombres, par forcément consécutifs, mais tous différents.
Et ce qui est intéressant c'est le cadeau que je te laisserai Kamille.
C'est qu'à la première ligne on a 8+11=19+55=74+1=75.
54+2=56+7=63+12=75.
3+57=60+9=69+6=75.
10+5=15+4=19+56=75.
Et si tu regardes bien, ou que vous vous mettez pause chez vous, sur la colonne 8+54+3+10, ça fait 75.
Ici aussi, on a 75, 75, et 75.
Et en même temps parce que quand même ça va faire presque 1an de volte vanne qu'on se connait
Dans la diagonale, 56+9+2+8=75.
Dans l'autre diagonale nous avons 10+57+7+1=75.
Les 4 cases au centre font 75.
Les 4 coins font 75.
Les 4 là font 75. Là on a 75. 75 ici, là, là, et ici.
-Trop facile...!
T'as rien compter. [rires]
Elle se dit, ça doit être bluffant, mais j'ai pas...
-C'est trop facile !
C'est un cadeau !
-Merci beaucoup Fabien Olicard.
Je ne te le signe pas, ça vaudrait trop d'argent et tu pourrais te faire agresser après.
-Oui ça serait dommage !
[rires] Donc je te le laisse comme ça.
-Ecoute, merci beaucoup Fabien Olicard.
Kamille est-ce que je dis aux gens de te suivre sur Twitter ?
-Oui suivez moi.
Suivez Kamille sur Twitter, son compte c'est "Kamille avec un K".
-Oui, alors il faut expliquer.
-Kamille avec un K, mais Kamille avec K,A,M,I,L,L,E A,V,E,C  un K.
En fait je vous mets le lien dans le descriptif, ce sera beaucoup plus simple.
Merci Kamille !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !